cuando quique regresó de vacaciones
volvió a encender la calefacción en su
casa puso la temperatura tan alta como
pudo su representa la temperatura en la
casa de quique en grados celsius después
de 'the minutos q es igual a 15 más 0.4
t cual era la temperatura cuando quique
regresó de vacaciones pausa en el vídeo
y traten de resolverlo por su cuenta muy
bien nos preguntan la temperatura y
puede ser que estén un poco confundidos
y que piensen que la t es la temperatura
no lo es t es el tiempo en minutos la
temperatura es q q representa la
temperatura entonces lo que realmente
quieren saber es cuál era la temperatura
q cuando quique regresó de vacaciones
bueno justo cuando quique regresó de
vacaciones es cuando te es igual a cero
esto equivale a decir cuál es el valor
de q nuestra temperatura cuando han
transcurrido 0 minutos
bueno si regresamos a esta ecuación
original
vemos que q es igual a 15
0.4 por la cantidad de tiempo
transcurrido en minutos este tiempo es
igual a 0 así que eso es igual a 15
grados celsius
si estás familiarizado con la forma
pendiente intersección puedes pensar que
nuestra temperatura es igual a 0.4 por
el tiempo transcurrido más 15 entonces
este es igual a 0 y sólo te queda este
término que en muchos casos lo
consideramos como nuestra intersección
en que está pasando justo cuando estamos
empezando justo cuando nuestra variable
horizontal es igual a 0 y nuestra
variable horizontal en esta situación es
el tiempo transcurrido cuanto aumenta la
temperatura cada minuto hay un par de
maneras en que puedes pensar en esto una
es que si reconoces que esta es la forma
pendiente intersección podrías ver que
0.4 es la pendiente esto significa que
por cada cambio de un minuto en el
tiempo vas a tener un aumento de
temperatura de 0.4 grados celsius así
que podrías hacerlo de esa manera y
podrías probar con alguno
valores podrías decir de acuerdo déjame
pensar en cuáles van a ser los valores
de cv con base en t entonces el tiempo t
es igual a 0 justo cuando llega a casa y
calculamos que la temperatura es de 15
grados celsius cuando t es igual a 1 que
pasa va a ser igual a 15 más 0.4 por 1
esto es igual a 15.4 fíjense que cuando
aumentamos nuestro tiempo en 1 nuestra
temperatura aumenta en 0.4 grados
celsius por la pendiente nuevamente lo
que sucede es que si aumentamos el
tiempo en otro minuto si pasamos de 1 a
2 obtenemos 2 y 15.8 incrementamos una
vez más la temperatura con un 0.4
adicional cuánto aumentará la
temperatura si quique deja la
calefacción encendida por 20 minutos
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
muy bien debemos tener cuidado aquí no
nos están preguntando cuál es la
temperatura después de 20 minutos están
diciendo
aumentará la temperatura si deja la
calefacción encendida por 20 minutos si
solo quisiéramos saber cuál es la
temperatura después de 20 minutos
diríamos bueno cuál es el valor de q
cuando t es igual a 20 entonces sería
igual a 15 más 0.4 por 20 0.4 por 20 es
88 más 15 es igual a 23 así que es igual
a 23 grados celsius después de 20
minutos pero eso no es lo que nos están
preguntando están preguntando cuánto
aumentará la temperatura bueno desde
donde empezamos empezamos desde los 15
grados celsius y ahora después de 20
minutos
hemos llegado a 23 grados celsius así
que hemos aumentado en 8 grados celsius
con otra manera de pensarlo podemos
decir que hemos aumentado esta cantidad
que tenemos aquí comenzamos a los 15 y
después de 20 minutos hemos aumentado en
0.4 por 20 qué
igual a 8 grados celsius hemos terminado